how's gum Roseman is pure fat and
welcome to Jake's that's why do we might
as well [ __ ] call this I needed that
key was too cold again [ __ ]
alright I didn't it let me just check my
emails maybe a marine rat Moran dad what
are you doing in Iran to 5:05 cool I
could have just added it but based on
into a chip I'm Sarah
we came here Puma Puma Puma interesting
keycards in the future it's really anti
innovation because I'm a large and
[ __ ] bigger large and bigger there
you go [ __ ] I forgot that by the
blueprint Lee I hate to die from a
blueprint but I wanted Molotov it's
great that you get so many weapons in
the game because all of them are [ __ ]
point that stinks a little doesn't it I
ants I have a piercing too now we can be
buddies well I wouldn't exactly call
that the best intro of a video but I try
so hard
lose it all in the end Michael Jackson
is still out there
it's interesting how you can still die
during these events in a lot of games
they don't I usually add that which is
kind of cool I have to say [ __ ] is one
of these
all right definitely picked us but lay
oh my god
where did he come from where did he come
from
this game is hard like I like that it's
hard if it's easy and you just breeze
through and it's not funny but I'm it's
this very random which is good cuz once
you learn the house stuff works in it or
a game it's over it's not scary anymore
[ __ ] how do I clear one Oh Jason
oh come on you cheated on me Oh God hi
it's on me go in there you stupid [ __ ]
that's right go in there you stupid hoe
you are stupid hoe you are you a stupid
hoe don't touch anything
Oh God
go that way police that would be great
it's going this way great that's what I
was hoping for Jesus where do you go up
the vent yeah you did hey man how you
doing that's what you get for making out
with my girlfriend Hey Hey You you I can
be your girlfriend no way no wait I need
a new one Hey Hey
yeah you want to be a girlfriend no no
way
shell out maxin relaxin all cool and all
shootin it's really cool it's right
[ __ ] about me that's it
hey nice glasses man you're looking
quite swaggy nothing well what is the
price it's not like the health matters
in this game anyway
it's friggin buy happy what's your [ __ ]
man
yes what is going on in here what the
[ __ ]
auto [ __ ] oh yeah this is the famous
I've got the nuts just we go through all
this with that girl I can't forgot about
how god I could have just gone in there
goddamn it
Oh God great I'm not moving I'm not
moving a [ __ ] inch [ __ ] this I'm a
man I'm a man god damn it
you think I'm scared do I look scared no
well thank you for the kinase captain I
wanna do this is just there I should
probably get the [ __ ] away from here
then good night
so the question is should I go back to
her to save air or should just [ __ ]
yellow my way through like I always do
[ __ ] Yolo my way through like I always
[ __ ] do they all love my way through
like I always [ __ ] do oh well how
nice of him to come invited uninvited oh
[ __ ]
I think he can hear me when I rule no no
no no no no no no no you don't want to
look for me I'm gonna chase him in the
[ __ ] face if he showed it up here dad
asked Oh hmm I would [ __ ] put some
motor oil on that [ __ ] and [ __ ] rub
my chicks all over that [ __ ] all right
we can do this exit how nice
now to do all that again we're gonna
we're just gonna take it cool I'm so
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] cooler than your ass
oh come on I think he sees me doesn't he
are you [ __ ] kidding me what's the
point if I can't do anything it's like
completely like oh you're dead now it's
like oh I'm sorry we got this we got
this we got this we got this come on
here we go well thank you more [ __ ] to
do that's really what I had up before
[Music]
Jesus what is this just want to go home
then cry
curl up to noodle bowl and cry is that
too much to ask
alright so this is where I am supposed
to go at least well that's an act
beautiful random D breeze and space and
all that stuff that's just great how are
you doing then you piece of [ __ ]
yeah I don't need more of your s to [ __ ]
me [ __ ] wait can you come in here
it seems very [ __ ] possible actually
sigh can I do anything with my life
alright there's two of them there we go
should be every running
hope that doesn't attract any beautiful
little aliens I'd be great
Oh God is it in here oh no they are out
now
[ __ ] come on what I'm one little man and
my name is Sam investigates and Chris
familiar why me though it's a methanol
I'll take it
really I could have [ __ ] saved save
station station thank God that I could
save at least that took me so much time
you bros have no idea all right there is
oh god he's coming look at that the
drool the drool
okay that's seriously gross man you know
there's medication for that disgusting
all right excuse me Lina they look great
but I have to do this all right let's do
this quick or do it in the slowest
possible [ __ ] pace what do I care
about life and living there we go
I hear something being friends with you
what else would I do
rrrow don't make me tasty bro bro like
don't even wrote don't even even me
right now don't even stephen me right
now excuse me I'm just gonna
you are gonna report my ass ha you're
funny what now okay run
[ __ ] you whoa let's do em let's take the
Harry's around
heylia's can't go here I'm safe
come on come on come on come on come on
come on baby now come on baby twist and
shout twist and shout come on come on
come on come on baby now what you know
now what Kato Lau hi I'm just gonna go
home
thank you no wait there's no home I shut
up episode
it's a nightmare issue oh my god nothing
has worked so far nothing what did I do
I ran like up here I should have got
come while I'm not gonna make the wrong
turn this time again make the wrong turn
once shame on me [ __ ] me [ __ ] you
I would did it we did it whatever there
whatever that I've never been a more
done with a place in my entire [ __ ] are
you serious
dad-dad
what is that dongsik Skrillex what are
you doing here what happened
[Music]
Jesus the barrels they exploded all this
time they were trying to save me how it
burns mr. burns
hi man how you don't let me lose you I
mean landscape God I like it Gabe
I'll be going this way thank you what
are you serious
ow it burns it burns so much yes yeah
thanks guys
I'm clicking me man I don't have to yes
now I have to click see I'm prepared
like that Wow
I got Jess we got this for us
I don't see why I would go up here is
beyond me but let's define shall we
sweetheart
[ __ ] Mirror's Edge this [ __ ] and
that's how I did climbing please what
happened I fell and died pretty serious
what did I do
come on come on that's where I found the
last night jade sits there we go that's
what I'm talking about
how's everyone doing here wait something
tells me we're not safe here either I'm
ready to stun [ __ ] oh yes I am
are we safe now please can we be safe
for like a minute I've been like running
around being dead for 40 minutes it's
it's been not that great for me and my
my my reputation of not being scared has
not really been going up it's probably
game going down I would say slide down
like it's nobody's business shout is in
the middle of the street right in my
head when I can't keep back I'm
a-thinkin like Nana Nana every day got
my ice cream stuck under pray I'm DK
o''h who left a bonding agent they're
like oh shut up where are we now oh we
made it
lovely lovely I'm looking forward to
never ever ever ever [ __ ] ever
go back to this place look at this
pretty lady I want to taste her nose out
don't you ever feel like there one night
it said yes to me well what are you
gonna do about it let's climb in this
bottle mmm British smoke in here I like
that I'm glad we haven't had any
encounters with alien in here maybe it
died actually
according to the map I've been here
before but I don't really recall
I don't to be hey that's my drinking
stash now I remember
now all those memories about my my
elders are coming back how about pipes
that's good to know that you are still
there cuz you never know this place is
falling apart yeah I keep thinking how
all of this could have been avoided if I
just did a better job at spacewalking
what the fudge cake are they doing in
surmising half-life 2 what are those
interesting Oh are they shooting guys
don't shoot
you're gonna alert that that thing whoa
Jesus no one told me the smoke bombs
we're so effective how well that worked
they're like [ __ ] this we're out of here
let's do some hacking brush I'm a great
[ __ ] hacker alright umm we are going
to remove the camera feed yes and that's
it no I'm just kidding and then we're
gonna give me door access cuz I'm [ __ ]
cool like that well that was fun should
we go up to them and say hello or should
we go to the faculty administration we
have so much ammo we might as well kill
some [ __ ] I have been the one in the
[ __ ] being killed the entire game I
think it's a damn about my turn to kill
some [ __ ] where they go guys that's
weird they're just left
oh well they're [ __ ] idiots well if
you don't find a cylinder in the right
spot ago and sing a song about wearing a
thong semester linked shave station
oh oh oh all right it's tasting time
hello gentlemen
well it just got hot in here huh you
know what if this was taken out of
context it would look like something
different
I'm just saying well that was fun let's
do that again sometime how well that
about does it get your vest oh we did it
Oh oh well I wasn't too bad was it
you scared ah it's been adorable so far
you're so scared this game man woman
alien dinosaur he says how do you
survive this far you're weird I love
this funky music and I love meet me in
the plastic bag that's that's some Cola
tea [ __ ] [ __ ] imported from five
years of space tomorrow no together
future oh shut up with your hips or
messages man I don't I don't need you
use a lever old RV press as interesting
feel like I did something I wasn't
supposed to be doing let's take a look
outside so that's the thing and that's
their spaceship god damn this place is
lonely
I can understand space loneliness
alright let's see what we got yeah we
got you we got you we got you I got you
babe I got you babe this is a lovely
TUI's isn't it this is like the
beginning doesn't it I'm starting to
feel like home
this is actually quite nice it looks
like oh shut up no Alexei oh we are back
finalmente señoras hallelu into a clear
directive not to land on station I told
you we didn't hear your message we
understood you would be Hey
oh it's de Marsh identify yourself
Ripley from the Torrens relax kid
nobody's called me baby going on here
Marshall where's the security forces
you're looking at them well we're [ __ ]
I've seen the creature what is it I
don't know something brought here by
Marlowe the captain made a Anissa Dora
we should have found the flight recorder
is there anywhere safe left on this
station that creatures running around
and the Sikhs and synthetics are less
than friendly goddamn and hey goddamn
Hannah needs attention medicals a no-go
we can't take her there we have a basic
life support unit back at HQ
then let's go we need the transit to get
to HQ but it's down got damaged
influence upstairs Samuel says you're an
engineer go make yourself useful
seeing as you screwed up the trap make
you eat your trash Yeah right we'll talk
about that later weights you protect
them while I'm gone understood
oh I was in the truck I'll get a lock in
a radio so we can stay in touch
peachie
we really should hurry Taylor
don't worry Samuels we'll get her out of
here I'm actually really worried and I
think we can do it
bye we're back in black there's no black
just try to be try to be nice I thought
there was a safe station here somewhere
get to transit control but how how how
does one get to transit control all
alone
when there's like a guy that can do it
for us
Ashton Kutcher in the future get out of
here man
get out of he where are we going then I
mean I remember pretty [ __ ] but not
like super [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
sound
what the [ __ ] was that I better be the
lightning or some [ __ ] nice hammer I
won't die Hammer axe hacks hey zing I
think it tells me to go in there all
right stupid
think you can stop me you orange
alien-looking son of a beast and you
nobody's stopping when Philippe is
popping what if pi is popping poor deep
eyes popping all right let's wait for
the elevator I suppose I'm gonna I'm
gonna go
what is this leaders parlor I don't know
about this Oh God
what was that no no come on this is a
miko Emma ho I'll never talk back to you
any mouth that area should be fine don't
look behind you it's okay don't panic
it's gonna be fine can be fine brass
woods let's [ __ ] him up
shut up flare watch my [ __ ]
name tube doggy
ja well that was fun let's do that again
sometimes baby girl snoop jokey Josh
[Music]
Snoop Doggy Dogg del RB and our our em
that's whoo not about desert all right
that opens up one of them what about the
rest
this place is weird main he's not coming
is he
oh yes clicking that should do it
Oh God
calm down [ __ ] [ __ ] just Android who is
he talking to he doesn't know I'm here
right
snip Jogi ja go
Oh God Oh God what okay
don't come in here did I break it sinks
in protocol is mentally challenged right
well that did that trick all right
what's going here where all those dead
people who are crawling around hi poets
did you miss me
shut up you stupid flare but I love you
I love you boots
you're a flare flares and capable of
love you [ __ ]
boots I'm sorry I tried to warn you ah
don't touch great you're British
[ __ ] oh he got me come on that's not
fair a gas torch I'm nice I've been
looking for you mate what's what sound a
new flat price not aluminium me I don't
even it will you be me all right well I
know where we can don't [ __ ] with me me
do not do the pocketer with me Tata
frittata rata tatata all right I got a
plan him race
throw it there nice now you won't see
anything now we can use the gas torch
alright it has a display you know it's
the future when the gas torch
Mookie's cool
come on yes [ __ ]
we're burning and coming home coming
um hey the world know I'm coming home
Nana but how is this how like how does
science work when when you try to twerk
into a muchacha burger bag I was English
a lot of my desert now for a little kick
and by Czech I mean ah but told Jesus
secret battles man I would better than
expected
hello say station oh god damn it it's a
hacking station I'll take it all right
what are we gonna hack today Bryce what
do you think air purification do we need
that [ __ ] now I would like some door
access though I'm big fan of that all
right that should do it
Claire I really need goddamnit who do
they hear this is gonna be bad
I have a multi bed at all right we need
to take one of them too
I am looking at it don't [ __ ] with boots
it sports will [ __ ] you up [ __ ]
what voices what is he talking about you
just want to scare me doesn't he
Oh God you [ __ ] serious myself play
it cool oh I'm in trouble I am in
trouble when you walked in it's a shame
me now whoops
oopsie
with let's use let's go find Sinclair no
way we should be splitting up safety in
numbers
alright see you later
give me one clear shot don't find me
please
[ __ ] morons [ __ ] idiots
ha that's how you sell for if Wanda
that's how you stealth can this please
go later noobs left one yeah I'm proud
of me laFonda alright let's keep playing
alien isolation if you made it this far
I could literally just say whatever and
you probably just stick around cuz
you're so I'm just saying it's been a
long series so far I'm surprised you
made it this long my god is it that the
new iPhone 200 toast your return oh it's
a drink well I guess that's I phones
there's drinks in the future that's it's
one waiting order
this way just let me save already sick
to my [ __ ] tummy [ __ ] you must
think I'm a [ __ ] dummy no
welcome committee
ya better not be an eight keep out but
the door says keep out hideaway it said
go right just up the sass what a lying
son of a sneak I have yeah hi oh it's
the marshal office [ __ ] the marshals
[ __ ] them gently well alright I guess I
got to do what's my duty it's my duty
don't make me [ __ ] you did you get the
transit running nice work oh you're
welcome sorry no you were talking maybe
safe here for now anyway space marshals
that's interesting you guys are like
space cowboys that's awesome did you
guys make those guys cuz those guys suck
I don't know if you realized it kind of
suck
alright well excuse me it's been great
chatting with you guys I'm gonna check
on Taylor my ex-girlfriend myspace there
we go I should say Dani
okay you can't be Marlo you're Marlon
Marlon
my name is Ripley I'm with the company
I'm here for personal reasons my mother
was on the Nostromo when it went missing
fifteen years ago
we never found her [ __ ] Ripley
but you sure as hell found something
else what happened up there
just start talking I want to know
everything cutscene right
I like cutscenes they're calling this
game give me something when I catch same
place
I waited eagerly for it oh my god whoa
what's this
okay enough already focus on what we're
here for I don't want any mistakes am I
on the nice drama that was Riley so
that's her mom his mom that's awesome
this is amazing okay Shane this is
Austin this is better than a cutscene
you have a fat nose press space to aim
the scanner are you there Ripley yeah
she must be Ripley she's like pink and
[ __ ]
director needle points to your director
okay there you are
Foster Meeks keep your eyes open
where the [ __ ] are we
what is this planet oh god you scare me
this is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] man I don't
I don't like space anymore can we not go
to space please that'd be great
all right the needle points yep
I'm finding something here guys I think
this is where the alien lives though
sigh and a chill it's not supposed to
blink red
hey where did that guy go there he is
come on don't go too far okay
we keep going we've got the tracker
it'll see us through Jesus don't worry
if it's a distress circle
they wouldn't have lasted which means we
get the salvage rights to anything we
find don't like where this is going
Berta chose that looks really creepy and
scary
yeah we're getting close all right
ain't nothing natural about this place
I'll have a look around see if I can
find a weak spot wait here
oh okay I guess I'll I guess I'll just
hang tight then find a way through the
blockage can we just go home please
gotta leave a lift over here give me a
leg up seriously
oh all right
help me up help me up higher now um I
found a path checking it out
then you wait some more
yeah you know what I don't care how much
you're paying me I wouldn't go here
ain't nothing natural about this oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god okay see you know
you're dead good job now you're a dead
man yeah it was a close one though don't
think I'll be able to get back the way I
came
yeah what was that I swear I heard
something I swear just God I will I
don't want to die at his face press
Jesus Christ what is happening here what
was that
hello is anyone out there
really stay put I think I found
something
no I don't want to find anything I want
to go back can I go back please there's
a fissure in the rock stand back I'm
gonna blow it yeah really this place
bombs and [ __ ] really how's that gonna
help anyone all right
a boom smacked sound in my heart and be
good oh Jesus
well that was fun let's do that again
sometime what did i do exactly
[Music]
let's get going follow me you're welcome
by the way
now scary super scary so alone and stuff
now what yeah this is it all right look
at that meter it goes up an hour but
what is this again that's why you were
here heist just to give me a leg up you
[ __ ] kidding me with these microphone
[ __ ] I've been trying for hours to
figure out what it is that does that to
my microphone I'm just gonna have to buy
all new equipment or some [ __ ] this is
ridiculous
sorry about that press
Oh guys I don't I'm quite positive that
that is not natural that is not natural
that is unnatural guys wait until you
see this oh god cutscene time again
could change my favorite time cutscenes
[Music]
time what just happened what was I what
was I
what that are we doing this again
I don't understand why are they social
about this this is so weird to me
that looks nasty
they're not seeing anything what the
[ __ ] they just enter like it's normal
okay no sure that's that's what I would
do to guys this is pretty creepy
something big something big I don't care
if it's small or big I don't want to
find it alright got in space and [ __ ]
we just couldn't stop we just couldn't
stop disgusting what is all this uh it's
like zits that I want to pop or some
[ __ ] well I hope they don't start engine
oh yeah what you touch I don't want
anything damaged Oh Kenneth we're
wasting time
have a look around
it was a life-form
now it's our property salvage rights
then we'll take what we can accompany
what else is here Trax what is it
ah I can see that [ __ ] that means we
should get a [ __ ] out of here let's find
out
I'll find the beacon and shut it off
don't want anybody else finding this
place
Foster heist check out the cavern below
so the Nostromo was the ship that came
before and found it
well no [ __ ] [ __ ] man
that looks so [ __ ] creepy - all right
well we have to find the beacon
what is this what all of these things
disgusting
no it doesn't oh we have to go up here
all right Thank You Man
doing a great job there I feel really
weird walking here breasts I don't know
if I like it or if I dislike it or if
I'd like it
whoa oh here we go
it goes up and down I don't understand
hello VIX I found the beak Jesus is a
distress beacon oh look there's shiny
balls wonderful oh and it's the mortar
guy how a motor a guy I'm just gonna
shut you off now by doing this yes
stroke it gently all holy ever wanted
was some loving I don't like this press
I don't like good a Cisco and I just
want to go home and cry can I please go
home and cry now
that'd be great thank you Bruce I don't
know man I don't like this at all I
don't like this one bit
it's so sexy though like holy [ __ ] it's
hot as [ __ ]
it's quite the ship huh
I look so cool
I just want to go home can I go home
Napoli's how long whoa what the [ __ ]
what's going on they're inside like that
use whinge are you serious
no you know what I'm good I'm good
all right well I guess not now this is
not a thumbs-up moment man this is I
want to go home and eat ice cream moment
what is all this
why do I have to do this I want to go
home don't touch them
[Music]
guys I wouldn't be so cuddly with us
look how many there are what the [ __ ]
oh god I hate them guys don't look at
them like that I want to go home I want
to go home now oh no oh yeah all right
well I've done that episode there if you
enjoy watching boats go ahead and hit
that like button
I really appreciate a say awesome Bruce
I love you
[Music]